okay so the topic that we're going to be
discussing today are the levels of
organization that exists within the
human body so let's go ahead and get
started so before we go into the levels
of organization I want to talk about
cells and how they become specialized
well here's an egg cell with 23
chromosomes in it you might remember
that egg cells are haploid and on the
night of fertilization a bunch of sperm
cells which are also haploid a bunch of
sperm cells are released from the father
now only one of these haploid sperm
cells is actually gonna penetrate and
fuse with the egg and that creates again
what's called a zygote a fertilized egg
created from the union of the of the
nucleus of the sperm in the nucleus of
the egg ultimately the rest of the sperm
cells are gonna eventually die but what
we're left with is a zygote let's talk
more about this
so that sigh goat is going to divide by
the process of mitosis where one the one
cell zygote divides and becomes two
cells the two divide by mitosis to make
four before become eight the eight
becomes 16 and what we end up getting is
this lump of cells called embryonic stem
cells what's interesting about embryonic
stem cells is if they have the potential
to become any type of cell in the body
they are cells that lack specialization
now as a woman's pregnancy continues
eventually a baby will be born and the
average human is made up of around a
hundred trillion cells and with over 200
different kinds of cells in the body but
we can trace these 200 types of cells
back to what are called embryonic stem
cells let's look at this in a little
more detail so when we look at embryonic
stem cells what we're gonna show you our
two processes called determination and
differentiation and this is what's
ultimately going to lead stem cells into
becoming specialized let's start with
the process known as determination so
this usually takes place early in
development chances are the mother
doesn't even real
that she's pregnant pregnant when the
process of determination takes place
what happens is that there are genes or
segments of DNA there are genes inside
of the nucleus of all of these that
begin to activate in a unique sequence
I'm gonna make genes comparable to light
switches and so what we have here are
nine light switches which are symbolic
of nine genes that exist within the
cell's nucleus now in reality we have
about 25,000 genes I'm illustrating only
nine but during the process called
determination different genes in DARAB
begin to activate so in the stem cell to
the left you can see that those those
genes marked on became activated but in
the stem cell to the right the same
genes to begin with but a different
combination of genes activate this is
what happens during determination genes
become active in the stem cells and this
process is irreversible
now this process is going to lead to the
process called differentiation so in the
process of differentiation this is where
the stem cells actually acquire the
structures and the functions of a
specialized cell so this is what at
what's going to happen is that this the
embryonic stem cell is going to produce
a very specific combination of proteins
you know just for simplicity I want to
remove all the other stem cells and just
highlight these two right here well
notice how the the cell the stem cell on
the left has a different combination of
genes that have been activated
this combination perhaps will allow the
stem cell to become a nerve cell
however the cell on the right because it
has a different combination of genes
activated thus on the right might become
a red blood cell the cells have
differentiated and become different
so as we move on now we can now focus on
cells the basic unit of life when we
look at how the body is organized yes
there's over a hundred trillion cells in
the body and there's over 200 different
kinds of cells but cells are the most
basic unit of life that can still carry
on and function on their own you might
know that cells of smaller parts to them
for instance a Golgi body but a Golgi
body removed is incapable of functioning
on its own a cell is the most basic unit
but cells themselves can be organized
into a larger unit you might know that
cells can be organized into tissues
tissues are groups of cells that work
together to accomplish a similar job and
there's really four different kinds of
tissue that I want to mention the first
being muscle tissue muscle tissue is
designed as stretch and contract your
muscles are designed to stretch and
contract if you want to straighten out
your arm and then curl your arm up the
cell of the muscle cells have to be able
to stretch and contract they have to be
flexible
skeletal skeletal muscle cells and
cardiac muscle cells these are examples
that you can find within the body when
you look at this picture right here
again here's a person's muscles of their
arm and you can see the biceps in the
middle you know when when this you can
picture this person's arm extending
straight word and then curling up and
extending straight word and curling up
and every time it it does the muscles
have to be able to stretch and be
flexible stretch an elongate when you
straighten out the arm and then bunch
back up when you curl the arm back up so
a second type of tissue is what is
called connective tissue the reason for
the picture here is because bone bone
fat tendons these are examples of
connective tissue another example you're
probably familiar with are called
ligaments we'll talk more about
ligaments in just a moment but again the
purpose of connective tissue is really
to support the body
so in this picture of the knee here if
you imagine your leg well your big leg
bone your big thigh bone is called your
femur and beneath your femur you have
your shin bone also called your tibia
well these two bones are connected by
ligaments ligaments are connected to
your femur and your tibia to really hold
your bones together you may have heard
of the blue ligament called your ACL and
the green ligament called your PCL but
there's also other ligaments that are
colored in grey well you can imagine
that these ligaments can be torn the
more stress you place on them you know
sports such as tennis volleyball
basketball football sports where you
constantly start stop change directions
jump put a lot of stress on these
ligaments to the point where they could
actually rip and tear off of the bone
and then they need to be surgically
surgically repaired but the purpose of
ligaments is to support the body in this
case these ligaments support your body
by connecting bone together so a third
type of tissue is is called epithelial
tissue and this is the tissue that's
really covering the covers and protects
parts of the body in the picture we see
various layers of skin cell skin cells
skin cells are great examples of
epithelial tissue
you also have epithelial inside of your
stomach lining the inside of your
stomach covering and protecting the
inside of your stomach against the
digestive acids that helped it break
down our food and so here's a picture of
some of the different kinds of
epithelial cells but again noticing that
they all really cover and protect that's
the purpose of epithelial cells and the
final type of tissue I want to mention
is called nerve or nervous tissue and
the purpose of nervous tissue is to
transmit electrical signals to and from
the brain you know if your brain wants
to send a signal to the foot maybe
you're playing a game of soccer and you
want to kick the ball your brain will
send them
message down your spinal cord avenge way
to the muscles in your foot and in
between your brain and your foot are as
a bunch of nerve tissue that is designed
to send that those electrical signals
well what about the next level of
organization you have what's called an
organ an organ is simply a collection of
tissues in the picture we see for
instance lungs lungs are our two are two
organs that are made of up of a
collection of epithelial T of epithelial
tissue connective tissue muscle tissue
and nervous tissue all types of tissue
make up what we call lungs and lungs are
just one kind of organ of course of
course the heart is an organ made from
all types of tissues the liver is an
organ made from different types of
tissues and so the next level of
organization up we would come to would
be an organ system it's a collection of
organs that all work together to
accomplish a purpose in the in the
picture it's the organs of the
respiratory system you can see the lungs
and the trachea and the larynx and the
pharynx these are all organs that
collectively make up what we call the
respiratory system and that's how we
breathe
you know we obtain nutrition by the
breakdown of food the esophagus the
stomach the small intestine the large
intestine these organs helped it break
and digest our food so we can obtain
nutrition here's a picture of the
endocrine system and you know the
thyroid gland in the thymus and the
adrenal glands the pancreas these organs
all release hormones and that's the main
function of the endocrine system it's
what controls the hormones in our body
and so ultimately we come to the upper
level of organization simply the overall
organism you know the human body is made
up of many organ systems working
together the human body is made up of a
nervous system the digestive system and
endocrine system a respiratory system a
circulatory system a reproductive system
the list goes on and on and the final
analogy I would like to make would be
these Russian figurine dolls right here
you've probably seen these before where
the small doll can be inserted into the
next one up and the next one in the next
one so for instance cells tissue organ
organ system organism represents the
different levels of the human body and a
cell so a bunch of cells make up what a
tissue and a bunch of tissues make up an
organ a bunch of organs make up an organ
system and several organ systems makes
up one organism so I hope that analogy
is clear to illustrate the levels of
organization within the human body and
so there you go if you're in my biology
class pause the video try to answer
these on a separate sheet of paper I'm
happy to check your answer is either
before a school or after school one day
good luck